Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Six, Episode Eleven: church and religion in Denmark.
There is freedom of religion in Denmark.
It ensures that citizens have the right to unite in religious communities to practise their faith in the way they wish.
Freedom of religion was written into the constitution in 1849 as one of the fundamental freedoms of the new democracy.
Freedom of religion means that the individual citizen can practise the religion he or she wishes.
Everyone can also freely change religion.
You can also choose not to be a believer.
All citizens in Denmark have the same civil and political rights, regardless of whether they have one, another or no religious faith.
Denmark's monarch, the king, is as the only person not covered by freedom of religion.
The constitution establishes that the monarch must belong to the evangelical Lutheran, Protestant, church.
The evangelical Lutheran church is the Danish national church, folkekirken, and is supported by the state.
This is established in the constitution.
The state gives grants to the national church.
The members of the national church pay a special church tax.
The church tax is a kind of membership fee for the national church.
It is therefore only members of the national church who have to pay church tax.
The Danish national church and Christianity have left many traces in Danish society.
Everywhere in the country churches stand as clear symbols of the long history of Christianity in Denmark.
Christianity has helped influence the development of Danish society.
Church festivals and holy days are still marked during the year.
And the Danish national church carries out on behalf of the state a number of tasks, for example registering births, naming and deaths.
The church has done this for several hundred years.
It is one of the characteristics of the Danish national church that no one can speak on behalf of the church.
The national church has no official spokesperson.
Nor does it take part as a national church in the political debate.
Most Danes regard religion as a private matter.
There is a tradition for distinguishing between religion and politics.
The Danish national church is often highlighted as being a broad and roomy church.
That means it makes room for significant differences in the understanding of evangelical Lutheran Christianity.
The majority of the Danish population, about 70 percent in 2026, is a member of the national church.
There are, however, large geographical differences.
In Copenhagen Municipality, 46 percent of the population are members, while in thinly populated areas it is typically far more, for example 84 percent in Jammerbugt Municipality in North Jutland.
Membership is voluntary, frivilligt.
You do not have to be a member of the national church to be a Danish citizen.
Roughly seven out of ten are members, not one in three or one in two.
A member of the national church can thus freely leave if they wish.
It varies greatly how often members come to church for services or on other occasions.
The national church's organisation is, like all other public institutions, democratic and builds on the members' participation.
Since ancient times the word "sogn", parish, has been used as the name of the geographical area where the local church's members live.
A church parish is led by a parish council, menighedsråd.
It consists of the parish's priests as well as members who are elected democratically by the congregation.
The highest administrative authority in the national church is the Minister for Ecclesiastical Affairs, kirkeministeren.
Long before freedom of religion was introduced, the king had given special permission for Jews as well as Roman Catholic and Reformed Christians to practise their faith in Denmark.
Since the constitution was introduced, citizens have used freedom of religion to form many different congregations or religious communities.
Some build, like the national church, on the evangelical Lutheran understanding of Christianity.
They simply wish to stand freely and independently in relation to the national church.
Others build on some of the many other understandings of Christianity that exist around the world.
In addition there are also congregations or religious communities in Denmark within most of the other religions that are most widespread in the world.
A group of citizens can freely form a congregation or a religious community.
It does not need to be registered or recognised by any public authority.
It does say in the constitution, however, that it is a condition that "nothing is taught or done that is contrary to morality or public order".
This means that in religious worship too, you must respect the other rules that apply in society.
Religious communities or congregations can themselves employ religious preachers, that is priests, imams, rabbis and so on.
They can also build or furnish buildings to practise their religion, for example churches, temples, synagogues or mosques.
You just need, as with all other building, permission from the municipality.
It is to ensure that the building can take place within the framework laid down in local plans and so on.
Congregations or religious communities can also set up schools.
They can get permission to establish burial grounds.
And they can of course, like everyone else, use freedom of expression, for example to publish religious writings.
A religious community whose purpose is to gather around a faith in powers, for example a god, which stand above humans and the laws of nature, can apply to be recognised as a religious community or as a congregation.
Such recognition gives the possibility of a series of special rights.
In the religious area, this concerns especially that the congregation's priest, or other religious leader, can get permission to perform weddings.
In 2026 there are a total of 435 recognised religious communities and congregations in Denmark.
Besides Christian ones, they include Muslim, Jewish, Buddhist and Hindu ones.
Recognised religious communities and congregations do not get direct financial support from the state.
The tax rules do however give various possibilities for them to get indirect support.
The second largest religious denomination in Denmark today is Islam, which comprises a number of different religious communities.
It is only membership of the national church that the authorities register.
Therefore there are no official statistics on how many citizens belong to the various other religions, congregations or religious communities in Denmark.
Here is your recap for Episode Eleven.
Freedom of religion was written into the constitution in 1849.
The monarch is the only person not covered: the king must belong to the evangelical Lutheran church.
The national church, folkekirken, is evangelical Lutheran and supported by the state; only members pay church tax.
The church registers births, naming and deaths.
No one speaks on behalf of the national church, and it has no official spokesperson.
About 70 percent are members in 2026: 46 percent in Copenhagen, 84 percent in Jammerbugt.
Membership is voluntary.
A parish, sogn, is led by a parish council, menighedsråd.
The highest administrative authority is the Minister for Ecclesiastical Affairs.
Religious communities need no registration, but must not teach or do anything contrary to morality or public order.
They can employ their own preachers, build churches, temples, synagogues or mosques with municipal permission, and set up schools.
Recognised communities can get permission to perform weddings.
In 2026 there are 435 recognised communities.
Islam is the second largest religion.
Authorities register only national church membership.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
Do all taxable citizens pay church tax?
Option A: Yes.
Option B: No.
[DA] Betaler alle skattepligtige borgere kirkeskat?  A: Ja  |  B: Nej
The answer is B: No.
It appeared in the June 2022 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Nej
Question 2.
Is it a requirement that a Danish citizen must be a member of the national church?
Option A: Yes.
Option B: No.
[DA] Er det et krav, at man som dansk statsborger skal være medlem af folkekirken?  A: Ja  |  B: Nej
The answer is B: No.
It appeared in the June 2021 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Nej
Question 3.
How large a share of Denmark's population is a member of the national church?
Option A: About 40 percent.
Option B: About 55 percent.
Option C: About 70 percent.
[DA] Hvor stor en andel af Danmarks befolkning er medlem af folkekirken?  A: Cirka 40 procent  |  B: Cirka 55 procent  |  C: Cirka 70 procent
The answer is C: About 70 percent.
It appeared in the May 2024 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: Cirka 70 procent
That's the end of this part.
Well done.